معنا في المتابعه من طول كارم مراسل
الجزيره ليث جعار اهلا بك معنا اذا نتابع
معك هذا الخبر العاجل لاستشهاد سته
فلسطينيين في ظل استمرار التصعيد
الاسرائيلي بالفعل وصل سته شهداء الى
مستشفى ثابت ثابت الحكومي في مدينه طول
كرم اضافه الى اصابه خطيره حتى هذه اللحظ
ظه يحاول الطواقم الطبيه محاوله انعاش هذه
الاصابه نتيجه لاستهداف مجموعه من الشبان
بطائره مسيره من قبل قوات الاحتلال خلال
العمليه العسكريه لجيش الاحتلال في مخيم
نور شمس قوات الاحتلال بعد محاصره المخيم
بالكامل تم قامت باستهداف مجموعه من
الشبان المدنيين كانوا في محيط المخيم
بطائره مسيره ما ادى لارتقاء سته شهداء
وصلوا حتى هذه اللحظه على الاقل الى
المستشفى فيما لا يزال عدد من الاصابات
يمنع الاحتلال بعضها من الوصول الى
المستشفى والبعض الاخر قام باحتجاز مركبه
الاسعاف التي يتواجد بها هؤلاء المصابين
قوات الاحتلال تنتشر في كافه محاور مخيم
نور شمس وعلى امتداد الطريق في مدينه
طولكرم تمنع مركبات الاسعاف من الوصول
الى داخل المخيم واجلاء الاصابات او تقوم
بتفتيش هذه المركبات الاصابات تم نقلها من
داخل المخيم مشيا على الاقدام بعد منع
الاحتلال لمركبات الاسعاف من المرور
عبر الحواجز التي وضعها على كافه المداخل
تم قام الشبان من بين زقاق المخيم باخراج
هذه الاصابات ومن ثم تسليم ها
الى الاسعاف والى الطواقم الطبيه لتصل الى
مستشفى ثابت ثابت الحكومي
وهي يعني مرتقيا و على الفور اعلن عن
استشهاد السته اصابات اضافه الى اصابه
سابعه حتى هذه اللحظه لا تزال في حاله في
حاله حرجه والاحتلال يمنع الطواقم الطبيه
من الوصول الى المخيم قوات الاحتلال في مح
حيط المخيم وا منطقه كتابه تحديدا تستهدف
منزل بعدد من الصواريخ من طراز انيرجا
وايضا تطلق النار صوب المنزل بشكل كثيف
بالتزامن مع هذا هناك اشتباكات مسلحه
اثناء مرور اليات الاحتلال العسكريه من
بوابه 104 او سن عوز ال الغرب من المدينه
باتجاه مخيم نور شمس الاشتباكات تدور في
محيط محور مخي
طول كرم مع هذه الاليات العسكريه اصوات
الانفجارات لا تكد تهدا في مدينه طول كرم
على وقع العمليه العسكريه التي لا تزال
متواصله حتى هذه اللحظه اكثر من اربعه
ساعات على بدء هذه العمليه العسكريه ويذكر
ان هذا الاقتحام هو الاقتحام الثاني خلال
اليومين اي ان الاحتلال امس ايضا كان قام
باقتحام مخيم نور شمس وهو الاقتحام الثالث
خلال اسبوع هذا يعني ان الاحتلال ماضي في
سياسته لمحاوله القضاء على العناصر
المسلحه في شمال الضفه الغربيه المحتله في
الوقت الذي كل وسائل اعلام الاعلام
العالميه تتجه نحو غزه وما يحدث من مجازر
بحق قطاع غزه شكرا جزيلا لك ليثا جعار
مراسل الجزيره كان معنا من تول
كارم